I want this who drove in in this find
out what it'll take for let's just see
if we can't close this deal now David
Letterman is visiting a village that has
no power the number that we hear about
Indians living off the grid is usually
somewhere between 300 and 400 million so
while that's just about a third of this
country it's the whole population in the
United States this is how the majority
of our customers live the old way of
providing power to communities
especially like this one doesn't really
work what we want to do is to bring
affordable clean power using our solar
power plants wire up this village and
offer each home reliable power supply
for as little as $2 a month there's two
things that we hear about all the time
when it comes to electricity and how it
changes people's lives at the village
level they get to stop burning dirty
fuels in our home to power lights they
stop burning kerosene they stop burning
diesel the other thing that we hear that
makes a big difference is extending your
productive day into the night time so
when the lights go out you can still
study for school she's studying her
bachelor's degree and before the
electric light how was that possible at
night that one light bulb
was changing their lives for the better
what they gain from that will grow
exponentially thank you so very much for
letting us come to your home thank you
very much it does give me hope
you